[Musique]
radio classique
l'édito politique avec le figaro
guillaume tabard l'invité politiqué jean
leonetti bonjour avec vous étiez
médecins ne vous êtes surtout donc le
président des républicains dans une
situation capitulation extrêmement
complexe on le sait maintenant un
président j'allais dire définitive sera
élu en octobre il ne pourra pas être le
candidat aux présidentielles nous allons
parler de tout ça en direct dans une
seconde mon cher guillaume tabard c'est
le jour les douars devant philippe le
vrai ministre deuxième discours de
politique générale avec beaucoup de
thèmes attendu la pma l'écologie et
surtout la mise en oeuvre d'un certain
nombre de décisions à caractère
économique notamment le financement des
baisses d'impôts oui c'est le jour des
graphiques car un discours de politique
générale ça ne se fait pas tous les
jours on le sait c'est le rendez vous
phare d'un premier ministre c'est aussi
le jour du douar philippe car on est
dans un moment particulier du
quinquennat après cette très longue
séquence gilet jaune grand débat
national
après un scrutin les européennes qui
étaient marqués notamment par un
déplacement d'une partie de l'électorat
de droite alors que l'on sait qu edouard
philippe incarne cette sensibilité de
droite au sein de la majorité
c'est à lui donc revient de lancer cet
acte ii du quinquennat
en même temps j'ai dit aux filles il
faut toujours relativiser la portée d'un
discours de politique générale il n'est
pas le premier des premiers ministres à
en faire plusieurs jean pierre raffarin
on en faisait un tous les ans donc en a
fait 3 est ce qu'on peut dire que jean
pierre raffarin fut le premier est plus
autonome le plus puissant de la vème
république
ça n'est pas évident françois fillon
également a fait plusieurs discours de
politique générale est-ce que ça empêché
nicolas sarkozy de le regarder comme un
simple collaborateur
ça n'est pas évident non plus alors si
en fait il ya un test important
aujourd'hui il est plutôt d'ordre
institutionnel que personnelles ou
politiques
vous savez l'éternel débat sur leur à la
relation entre le président république
et premiers ministres ya des tonnes de
littérature compte est écrite sur le
sur le sujet ce qui est clair c'est que
emmanuel macron a renoncé à s'exprimer
devant le congrès pour laisser son
premier ministre parlait devant
l'assemblée et puis ensuite demain
devant le sénat c'est une volonté en
tout cas délibéré chez lui de marquer un
sorte de rééquilibrage institutionnel de
re2 les deux retours un lecture peut
être plus originel de la vème république
où le président fixe le cap et où le
premier ministre est responsable de la
mise en oeuvre de la politique ça c'est
sur le papier car après il ya le
tempérament des hommes
et est ce qu'on est sûr qu'il maniait de
mâcon est vraiment un tempérament à
s'effacer durablement derrière son
premier ministre et à l'heure donc les
sujets dont on va parler évidemment au
lendemain de cette intervention de la
ministre
c'est un des l'interventions ce point de
lendemain donc à 15 heures il ya la
fiscalité la bge un pourri à la pma ya
l'écologie a beaucoup de sujets qui sont
sur la table qui n'ont pas vraiment de
réponse pour l'instant
oui et puis aussi surtout cette question
politique c'est edouard philippe va-t-il
être capable ou non d'élargir la
majorité
alors on va bien sûr scruter le résultat
du vote notamment des députés du groupe
agir u10 et même de ce que vont faire
une partie des députés l air là encore
retour aux intuitions ses traditionnels
que le premier ministre ait deux rôles
chef du gouvernement et celle de la
majorité c'est de la majorité on le voit
en ce moment à la manoeuvre a tenté
d'attirer des mers et l'air même si
parfois il ya peu de grosses ficelles de
la communication comme cette fameuse
appel de 72 mer dont on a découvert que
la quasi-totalité étaient en fait déjà
passer du côté de la majorité mais
surtout pour les électeurs notamment les
électeurs de droite qui peuvent être
sensibles à l'action ou au discours du
chef de l'état ce qui compte ça va être
plus le contenu des mesures qui vont
être annoncées d'où la liste que vous
n'êtes d'égrener que le nombre de
députés qui vont voter ou non la
confiance ou qui vont ou non
s'abstenir c'est donc sur son rôle de
chef du gouvernement
plus de que de celle de la majorité qui
doit philippe à pouvoir ou non se faire
un nom dans l'opinion
voilà donc l'éditorial avec nos avis du
figaro donc de guillaume tabard ce matin
pour la télévision je vous signale pour
les amateurs d'art
car en 2h 45 sur arte il y à un
documentaire consacré à marcel duchamp
l'inventeur notamment des raids email et
8h18 nous sommes en direct avec jean
leonetti
radio classique l'invité de guillaume
durand avec le figaro genre les ti
bonjour bienvenue sur l'antenne de radio
classique
on a le sentiment que beaucoup de textes
qui ont été initiées par la majorité ont
été votés par les républicains seront
par exemple la loi travail au tout début
ce que vous avez l'impression qu'à
partir de ce matin il y a dans votre
formation un changement se dire que vous
allez vous retrouver dans une situation
d'opposant systématique on l'a jamais
été on le saura jamais ce qui assez que
la dernier discours d'edouard philippe
l'immense majorité des députés
républicains se sont abstenus au fond
ils ont fait à et ils lui ont donné sa
chance si j'ose dire à ce gouvernement
et ils ont cru en partie ce qu'ils
adorent ces or aujourd'hui les résultats
sont pas au rendez-vous ni sur le plan
social la sphère du gilet jaune montre
bien qu'il ya une fracture sociale dans
notre pays même si c'est à coup d'arsys
même ça a coûté une vingtaine de
milliards oui et même ça plombe les
déficits
ben vous avez vous avez donné vous même
la réponse est le deuxième et sans qui
une autorité de l'état qui se soit
affirmée de manière rassurante pour
l'ensemble des français
le deuxième point et qui va être le
point important aujourd'hui c'est est ce
que ces annonces seront financés et on
voit bien qu'elles ne le sont pas en a
parlé de deux dames passe budgétaire
oui ce gouvernement est dans une impasse
budgétaire il n'a pas les moyens de
financer ce qu'il annonce donc ça veut
dire que vous allez non pas mal donc
abstention voté contre
écoutez je crois que la vie n'est elle
pas voter la confiance la meilleure des
choses voudrait confiance ça me paraît
difficile dans le contexte d'abstention
sur la vitre en sueur et l'opposition je
crois qu'on va écouter ce que dit le
premier ministre si le premier ministre
allait jusqu'à expliquer de manière
concrète de manière claire de manière
transparente
comment ils financent et comment il va
arrêter les déficits publics comment il
va arrêter la dépense de l'état
bah là où on voit bien que lourd là il y
aurait il y aurait un tournant non pas
de rigueur mais mais mais de lucidité or
aujourd'hui c'est un état qui dépense
toujours plus qui creusent toujours plus
de déficits qui augmente toujours la
dette et qu'ils ne nous explique pas
comment il va faire pour baisser les
impôts d'ailleurs de temps en temps il y
les baisses d'un côté pour les aux
plantes et de l'autre comment vous
expliquer donc dans ces conditions c'est
dans ce descriptif que vous faites une
grande passer votre électorat et soit
passé du côté de la réplique en marque
non seulement dans les quartiers
bourgeois de paris n'est même pas très
loin de chez vous puisque vous êtes à
antibes à nice où on a vu qu'une
majorité des gens avaient voté pour la
république en marche
je crois que on est d'un meilleur
président de droite elle dit mme
emmanuelle mignon à propos d' emmanuel
macron l'ancienne collaboratrice de
nicolas sarkozy oui bon je pense qu'elle
devrait réactualiser ses logiciels et
regarder la réalité des choses dans la
réalité des choses on est en train et
c'est un autre danger de rentrer dans la
dans l'histoire du parti unique c'est à
dire que faut-il et 1% il a bien réussi
à faire penser aux français qui avait
que deux choix le choix des extrêmes et
du chaos bien le choix du soutien au
président la république
je suis d'ailleurs assez surpris de voir
qu'un certain nombre de gens disent je
veux que la france réussisse et tout le
monde dans ce pays à majorité opposition
veut que la france réussisse est donc
née c'est là que c'est paradoxal je veux
que le président la république
réussissent mais si demain le président
de la république et de gauche la droite
peut le soutenir si demain le président
de la république s'appelle marine le pen
repas la soutenir donc il ya là dedans
1 1 un déni démocratie vous auriez été
l'objet d'un chantage c'est pas la faute
de laurent wauquiez ni la grande île a
tous bien sûr que c'est notre faute
attendait ne me faites pas dire ce que
j'ai pas dis je les vois pas il faut que
les bords de la vérité sorte
bien sûr je pense que nous avons
aujourd'hui à un socle électoral kiné
qui n'a rien à voir avec le socle
électoral que nous avions lorsque nous
avons créé l'ump
le mpr le ccd famille libérale c'est des
familles centristes c'est des familles
de gaulliste ces familles là tous ils se
réunissent bayari pécresse est parti
vous avez une explication
oui j'ai une explication qui ait quoique
plutôt personnelle le secret des
idéologies kba expliquez moi la
différence qu'il ya entre ce que dit
valérie pécresse
est ce que je dis moi par exemple ils
répartiraient pas beaucoup et le
deuxième question c'est on m'a dit
pendant longtemps le problème c'est
laurent wauquiez bon laurent wauquiez
démissionne et il le fait avec dignité
et avec raison
alors à ce moment là il ya une élection
pourquoi au moment où l'ouverture se
fait au moment où la démocratie à
l'intérieur du parti permet à ceux qui
pensaient que laurent wauquiez avait
fait des erreurs et l'un a probablement
fait comme d'autres de pouvoir accéder à
la gestion du parti
c'est à ce moment là qu'ils s'en vont
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il ya
d'autres réseaux et à quelle est cette
raison la raison c'est que on est dans
des écuries présidentielles beaucoup
plus que dans la refondation du parti et
moi je pense qu'il faut mettre en avant
serait qu'un pécresse et son ambition je
le pense voilà enfin sinon pourquoi
faire ça il est dans la droite qu'à
droite a toujours été un parti où les
rivalités été extrêmement forte jusqu'à
la liste chirac balladur qui de rivalité
c'est pas normal mais lorsque l'échéance
électorale approche on est à trois ans
des présidentielles
on a une élection municipale en tête
sont morts parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui l'ont dit y compris des jambes
droites comme eric zemmour
éditorialistes des républicains s'est
terminée cela n'existe plus ceux qui
disent ça c'est ceux qui le souhaitent
moi je le souhaite pas je le crois pas
je pense que les valeurs fondamentales
de la droite et du centre existe encore
et qu'elles sont pas représentés par
monsieur macron et donc je pense que
pour ce pays et pour mon parti nous
avons tout intérêt à redresser la tête
parce que un jour à force de jouer c'est
moi ou le chaos
un jour c'est le chaos est ce que vous
pensez parce qu'on a aussi vu ça dans un
sondage qu'une partie des électeurs de
droite
majoritaire souhaitait que nicolas
sarkozy joue un rôle
alors est ce que c'est une sorte de 2d
réalisme qui continue à exister chez
recteur de droite ou est-ce qu
effectivement il faudrait dire à sarkozy
je vous d'après vous qui êtes le
président donc les républicains
actuellement joue un rôle en tout cas un
rôle qui permettent d'aider à la
reconstruction
je crois que nicolas sarkozy a toujours
été clair là-dessus il n'y aura pas de
retour de nicolas sarkozy sur la scène
politique mais il ne peut pas ne pas
s'intéresser au parti auquel il a
appartenu qui l'a amené au pouvoir et
qu'il a en grande partie organisée donc
sa voix compte
mais ne demandons pas nicolas sarkozy
qui a été président de la république de
mettre les mains dans le cambouis sur
les affaires actuelles des républicains
américains doivent doivent se redresser
doit se redresser dans dans les idées
dans le renouvellement des idées on peut
pas vivre sur le logiciel de 2002 il ya
des éléments qui sont arrivés depuis une
le break 6 était arrivé la migration a
été plus forte et les attentats
terroristes sont arrivés aussi on a eu
une préoccupation écologique de leur
banc durable donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle les valeurs fondamentales de la
droite doit être réaffirmée et je n'ai
pas l'intention de faire l'intérim dans
lequel on aura qu'une préoccupation
c'est comment on fait l'élection du
futur je pense pendant ces quatre mois
il faut qu'on travaille sur les valeurs
fondamentales de la droite et c'est ce
que je vais proposer dans un no
convention avant la fin de ce mois et
ensuite dans un débat à l'intérieur du
parti avec des sympathisants
les électeurs de la droite et du centre
ils sont encore là nos précédents donc
ça sera en octobre
ça sera en octobre nos électeurs ils
sont partis mais sont pas loin oui
suffisait conjointe ils sont chez les
autres bah ils sont momentanément chez
les autos sa bn électeurs ça
n'appartient pas à un parti ça
appartient à personne sa partie à sa
conscience
merci mille fois et les huit heures 26
minutes sur l'antenne de radio classique
nous étions avec jean leonetti donc
président par intérim des républicains
et voir philippe seta 15h aujourd'hui
donc à l'assemblée nationale
il est huit ans 26 bonne journée à vous
gassin
[Musique]